bueno en puerto rico tenemos una tasa de
feminicidios de 3 que cuando la
comparamos a nivel internacional se
considera una tasa de feminicidios alta
las causas son variadas pero sabemos que
en esencia se trata de un sistema de
valores y de creencias que sigue
considerando a las mujeres como objetos
inferiores o desechables como se
manifiesta bueno no solamente a través
de los feminicidios sino a través de
otros múltiples y otras múltiples
expresiones de la violencia de género
como agresiones sexuales violencia
doméstica acoso etcétera en puerto rico-
esta tasa de feminicidios y la llevamos
a un conteo semanal estamos diciendo que
se asesina una mujer cada 7 días es
decir tenemos mínimo 52 homicidios
durante el año en nuestro país eso
provocó que desde el año 2018 las
organizaciones de mujeres en primer
lugar decretamos un estado de emergencia
eso ocurrió en julio de 2018 y a partir
de ese año le exigimos al gobierno que
decretar un estado de emergencia para
que respondiera a la violencia en efecto
ese estado se decretó ahora en enero de
y se generó o se creó un comité
interagencial y multisectorial que está
generando respuestas a la violencia de
género las respuestas están encaminadas
a prevenir la violencia hacia las
mujeres pero también a mejorar las
respuestas del sistema y a poder ofrecer
también instrumentos que nos permitan
validar y medir si esa respuesta en
efecto es lo que necesitamos para bajar
la tasa de feminicidios en la isla y de
otros eventos de violencia de género y
volviendo al caso de que isla en que van
las investigaciones verdejo está acusado
junto a un presunto coautor
eso es correcto él está acusado eso
pareciera haber cerrado la pregunta
abierta que teníamos de quién asesinó a
qué island sin embargo nos toca todavía
enfrentar un proceso judicial en la
corte federal de los eeuu que tienen
aquí en san juan de puerto rico como muy
bien dijiste el crimen por el que fue
ajustado pudiera acarrear la pena de
muerte y vale la pena aclarar la
constitución de puerto rico- prohíbe la
pena de muerte y aún nosotras las
feministas las que trabajamos por otras
mujeres nos oponemos a que esta pena sea
aplicada en este caso si nos queda un
caso por probar sobre todo que siempre
nos preocupa cuando un caso se
fundamenta exclusivamente en el
testimonio de un coautor así que estamos
a la expectativa de que otra evidencia
tiene la policía de puerto rico y la
fiscalía federal para sustentar su caso